what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the fifth episode of the falcon
and the winter soldier has been released
and it was over an
hour long 61 minutes if you're counting
the credits which you know they do count
we don't count but they count but
we did get a mid credit scene this time
and a rather good one that's definitely
foreshadowing some events that are about
to happen in the final episode of the
falcon and the winter soldier
which is the next episode episode six
that and the ending
of this episode gives us a lot of hints
of a lot of things that are going to
happen
in the finale and this will be my ending
explained in post-credits scene
explained video
breaking down everything that happened
at the end of this episode and what it's
going to lead up to
in the next episode and then of course
on saturday it will be my full
episode breakdown so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and i'm also giving away a
captain america shield right now
details of how to enter the giveaway are
in the description and the pin comment
down below
so let's start off in this video with
that mid credit scene with john walker
because he was a pretty big part of this
episode
now john walker story arc has definitely
changed
since the very first time we saw him now
let's be honest he was kind of a dead
man to begin with in this fandom we all
love captain america steve rogers played
by chris evans and this was a new guy
coming in to take his place he didn't
really have a chance
however in the second episode when you
met him you kind of wanted to give him a
chance but then he goes and says things
like stay the hell out of my way
however they've done a pretty good job
at trying to make you sympathize with
him
especially in this episode it starts off
with him running to a warehouse by
himself
right after he killed one of the flag
smashers in front of a lot of people
they were all filming so essentially the
world knows what he's done
sam and bucky confront him he refuses to
give up the shield
they fight and he almost actually beats
them but sam and bucky come out on top
he then goes to court where he deals
with the senate and is stripped of his
captain america title the senate refuses
to listen to him so he simply walks away
stating
i am captain america then we get to the
post-credits scene in the post-credits
scene we see john walker making a new
captain america shield
and there are a few things to talk about
here but first and foremost
this shield is not going to be anything
like his
old shield his old shield is made out of
vibranium
the most rare and precious metal on
earth and as far as we know
the strongest there really is no
replacing vibranium unless we're talking
about adamentium
but there is zero chance that john
walker got his hands on some adamentium
so this shield that he is making himself
is going to be
inferior by a lot it is not going to be
anywhere near as good as the vibranium
shield that used to belong to captain
america steve rogers
now john has kind of gone off the deep
end though he believes that he is doing
the right thing
the flag smashers are a terrorist
organization who are hurting people and
they killed his best friend so he
retaliated
in his mind he just killed a terrorist
so john walker believes that he truly
is the new captain america whether the
us government decides so
or not so john walker is taking things
into his own hands and he has decided
himself that he
is indeed captain america he forges a
new shield putting some of his medals on
it like his medal of honor and the
shield now becomes a symbol of what he
himself believes in
and he's going to go after the flag
smashers why because
carly is actually the one who killed
lamar now he lied to lamar's parents
stating that it was actually nico who
killed him and he killed nico
so lamar's parents think that the person
who killed their son is
dead so jon has unfinished business and
he sets out to kill carly but
he builds his new captain america shield
first and he is definitely going to join
the fight in new york
in the finale and the final battle is
set up in the ending of this
episode and there are a few key parts to
the ending
one of the key parts is what seems to be
the conclusion of
zemo's storyline in the falcon in the
winter soldier bucky finds zemo at the
sokovia memorial and zemo actually knew
that bucky was going to come for him
bucky decides not to kill zemo but to
turn him into the dora milaje they come
and take him and explain that they're
going to take him to the raft
the raft is a maximum security prison
located in the middle of the ocean we
actually saw this in captain america
civil war
this is where half of the avengers were
taken after the battle in the airport in
captain america civil war this is where
tony came to visit them and then
eventually captain america broke them
out
this is where the dora milage are taking
zemo but
before the dora milaje leave bucky asks
for a favor
this favor is the briefcase that bucky
ends up bringing
sam and what's in the briefcase a
captain america
falcon suit it's essentially a captain
america suit with wings but
this is going to be a very very
different suit than we've seen before
because this is made in wakanda
we can probably assume that the wings
are going to be made out of vibranium
and it is possible that the actual suit
is going to be made of the same material
that black panther suit was made out of
laced with vibranium as well
and it would be really cool if it had
the same ability such as absorbing
energy and then
releasing that energy as a blast so in
the briefcase that bucky brought sam
is his new captain america suit that
still has the falcon
wings bucky ends up staying the night
over at sam's place and then on the next
day before bucky leaves
they kind of start to develop their own
friendship as they talked about they
were both just two people who had a
common
friend and now sadly that friend steve
rogers
is gone and sam actually says steve has
gone a couple of times here but before
bucky leaves he actually reveals
something that we didn't know happened
in avengers in-game
bucky says when steve told me what he
was planning
i don't think we understood what it felt
like for a black man to be handed the
shield
how could we and then he apologizes to
sam
it's a very real scene and it also
reveals that in avengers in-game behind
the scenes that we didn't see
steve actually told bucky what his plan
was steve told
bucky that he was going to give the
shield to sam which means he actually
told him as well
that he was going to stay back in time
and spend the remainder of his years
with his love
peggy carter something that we weren't
really 100 sure about before but we kind
of expected that steve told bucky about
his plan
after all in the mcu he was pretty much
his childhood best friend
bucky and sam part ways bucky is going
back to new york and sam
starts to practice with the captain
america shield and by the end of this
awesome scene he definitely gets the
hang of it we then cut to a scene
with the flag smashers they're in the
middle of a park and carly says i got
some help to even the odds
this is where george's bar truck aka
bartrock the leaper shows up
you may remember him from the very first
episode of the falcon and the winter
soldier he is part of the group laf
and he was the one responsible for
kidnapping captain
vassant of the united states air force
in which falcon
defeated him thwarted his plan and got
captain vassant back
now this person is who sharon carter was
actually calling on the phone
during a scene in episode 5. sharon
calls somebody on the phone and says i
have a job for you and if it weren't for
me
you'd be rotting in that algerian prison
she then says i can give you double this
time
i promise you won't regret saying yes
now what she's referring to is actually
something that happened in captain
america the winter soldier
bartrack was actually in the winter
soldier he was the leader of the group
of pirates that hijacked the ship the
lemarian star
he fought captain america one on one in
hand-to-hand combat in which captain
america knocked him out
however he woke up and then threw a
grenade at steve but of course steve was
fine
bartrog managed to escape but he was
later found in algiers and was arrested
by shield
now we find out that nick fury actually
hired him to hijack the boat and we find
out here that sharon carter was actually
responsible for getting him out of
prison once he got out he joined laf and
then we saw him in the very first
episode of the falcon in the winter
soldier
and he now wants to kill falcon which is
very interesting because
sharon hired him to help the
flagsmashers
so sharon carter's role in this is still
very unknown
but she is indeed helping the flag
smashers because the deal was
bar truck brings the flax master some
help and he gets to kill falcon
so sharon is doing some shady stuff here
however i don't believe that she's bad i
think she has a secret plan that they're
not going to reveal to us until the
final episode
but right now it does seem like she is
helping the flag smashers out she's
clearly been involved somehow
and let's just hope that she remains
good and helps out sam and bucky in the
end
now carly ends up revealing her
following the flag smashers have a lot
of people backing their cause and she
says that tonight
they're going to battle they're going to
make sure the grc
doesn't vote on whether or not to send
refugees back to their own countries and
it's revealed that they are in fact in
new york where the grc vote is going to
take place
the flag smashers want worldwide unity
they don't want there to be any borders
between countries
so the fact that the grc is voting on
sending refugees back to their countries
is terrible to them we then see the grc
actually taking a vote which really
isn't a vote the u.s senator pretty much
decided that all of the refugees are
going
back everybody is in place to actually
send the refugees back
but the meeting is interrupted because
as it turns out the black smashers have
already
infiltrated the grc meanwhile at the
same time
sam gets a call from torres torres has
been able to ping the location of the
flags masters in new york
he says the location may be false but as
sam is watching the tv he sees that the
grc is meeting and voting
in new york and he knows that's where
the flax masters are and he knows that
they're going to attack the grc
he then goes to the suitcase that bucky
gave him and he opens it looking at his
new
captain america suit but of course it
doesn't
show us that's the final scene we'll see
it for the very first time in the finale
of the falcon and the winter soldier so
next episode we're going to have the
flag smashers attacking the grc
bucky and falcon reuniting of course
falcon will now be
captain america when we see him john
walker is going to continue
being captain america on his own terms
and go after the flag smashers and then
of course bartrack the leaper is going
to try and kill falcon and sharon
carter's involvement in this whole
entire deal will be revealed
and hopefully we'll finally find out who
the power broker is
all of this in the next episode of the
falcon in the winter soldier the finale
so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest falcon in the
winter soldier videos and of course look
out for my full breakdown of episode 5
coming out saturday
in the meantime let me know what you
would rate this episode in the comments
down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof